I
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast exploring the great indoors
relevance of the built environment to
human health I am Robert Castellanos of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider for virtual events
webinars and advancing scientific
collaboration and learning for more
information please visit Lavin's com
before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear you from
this interactive live broadcast so
please ask questions and you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing your comments and questions
and we'll try to get to as many as we
can want a better look you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
please let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or use a
Q&A button and we'll make sure to
resolve any issues that you may have
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing educational
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the C button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process to obtain your
credits well today we are pleased to
present dr. Roxanna Hickey dr. Roxana
Hickey is a macro law ecologist and
postdoctoral fellow at the University of
Oregon biology and the built environment
center her research is motivated by
uncovering the causes and consequences
of variation and the trillions of
microorganisms inhabiting the human body
collectively known as a human bio at the
bio ve Center she's working with
biologists have architects engineers to
study the microbiological relationships
between humans and the indoor
environments in which we spend most of
our lives this work will ultimately
contribute to a greater understanding of
the
all of the built environment micro room
to human health and development without
further ado I would like to welcome dr.
Hickey
thank you Robert for that introduction
and I want to start by thanking the
organizers of this really cool series
this is a great opportunity for me to be
able to share some of my research and
research from the biology and built
environment center at the university of
oregon and i also want to thank everyone
in the audience today i know that you
could be watching the new apple release
of the iphone right now so i appreciate
you taking the time to spend with me and
hear about some of the research that we
have going on at the biology and built
environment center so the title of my
talk today is exploring the great
indoors and i want to take you on a
journey through some of the research
that we've done in the last over the
last six to seven years exploring what
the composition of the indoor microbiome
is and how that relates to the human
microbiome and health and so to get
started i'll just provide a little bit
of background about the human microbiome
and I know that this is an area that
many of you are familiar with especially
those of you in the clinical sciences
and so just to give a very brief
overview the human body is teeming with
trillions of microorganisms including
bacteria fungi viruses and even
eukaryotic microbes we find bacteria and
other microbes throughout every almost
every body site that we've evaluated and
so we find lots of them in the gut
microbiome we also have microbes living
on the skin environment the oral cavity
urogenital tract pretty much everywhere
we look there are microbes current
estimates indicate that there's probably
around thirty nine trillion microbial
cells in a single human body and so this
constitutes somewhere between one to
three percent of the total of your total
body mass and so it's a pretty
significant proportion of what makes you
you and as we continue to learn more
about the functions of these microbes in
human health we're coming to realize
that they play a really significant role
in both maintaining health and
preventing disease but even still after
10 to 15 years of really intensive
research on the human microbiome we're
still only beginning to understand the
many functions that they served for us
and so just to highlight a few bullet
points of some of the areas in which the
microbiome is important to human health
I've just listed a couple here and
sure that you'll see talks throughout
this lab route see Ruiz touching on some
of these in more depth but microbes in
our gut for instance perform metabolic
activities that we can't do for
ourselves and so they contribute to our
nutrition microbes on our skin and in
our gut help protect against pathogens
and disease microbes are important for
training our immune system from an early
age and helping prevent allergies later
in life and a more recent research has
shown some interesting connections
between the microbiome and development
of disease and also development of our
cognitive behavior and mental health and
so I'm not going to get into any of
these areas today but I just wanted to
highlight that this is a very broad
field and there's a lot of active
research happening right now to try to
explore the role of the human microbiome
in human health and so as we've learned
more and more about the human microbiome
over the last 10 to 15 years we're
increasingly recognizing that microbes
don't only live in and on our bodies but
also in all of the areas around us so we
know that if we go into the outdoors we
find microbes in soils and on plants and
on other animals and so we're beginning
to appreciate more and more that
microbes really are all around us we
live in a microbial world and the
environment that we're really interested
in here at the biology and the built
environment center is the environment of
buildings and so humans in developed
countries spend a vast majority of our
lives indoors up to ninety percent of
our time I mean if you think about what
you're doing right now you're probably
sitting at a desk watching me speak on
your computer and you're in an indoor
environment being exposed to microbes
that are circulating in the air around
you and so given that we spend so much
of our lives indoors this makes for a
really interesting and important
ecosystem to study to understand how it
might be shaping both our human
microbiome and our health status so the
biology and the built environment center
is based at the University of Oregon and
this is a synergetic collaboration
between multiple groups of biologists
and architects and engineers and in in
both jessica greens laboratory which is
the lab that i work in and also the
energy studies and buildings laboratory
which is a consortium of arc
Engineers and at the bio de Center we
perform research to understand the
impacts of architectural design on
microbial ecology of the indoors in
order to inform sustainable design of
buildings and also promote healthy
conditions while conserving energy and
building design so the bio de Center as
i said is based at the University of
Oregon and it was founded in 2010 by dr.
jessica greene along with dr. Brendan
Bohannon and Charlie Brown also at the
University of Oregon and we're funded by
the Alfred P sloan foundation so we're
on our second grant cycle right now and
today the center is co-directed by dr.
Greene and also dr. kevin vanden y
mellenburg who is an architect in energy
studies in buildings laboratory so the
ultimate goal of the research that we do
at the by obe center is to be able to
optimize the design and operation of
buildings in order to promote human
health and environmental sustainability
and so when we think about the ways that
we design buildings and design projects
to understand the relationship between
building architecture and the human
microbiome there's kind of three
interacting areas that were interested
in and so these are microbial ecology
human health and building design and
energy now today I'm going to be
focusing more on the bottom portion of
this triangle looking at the
interactions between architectural
design and microbial ecology but we're
ultimately interested in connecting all
three of these together so to motivate
the work that I'm going to show you
today this is kind of a central question
motivating the research that we do and
this is how does the design use and
occupancy of buildings influence the
indoor microbiome and so I'm going to
highlight results from several studies
that have been published since the
initiation of the by obe Center and I've
split these into three categories here
and so if i get my pointer out here oh
there we go and so the first couple of
studies here illustrate how
architectural design impacts the
composition of the indoor microbiome the
next couple of studies that i'll show
talk about the ways in which humans
interact with the built environment so
either through direct contact with the
environment or some of the chemicals
that
might apply indoors and then finally the
last most recent study that i'll present
shows how humans are contributing
directly to the built environment simply
by occupying a space and so all of these
studies represent different ways that
we're trying to understand how human
intervention both through building
design and also just through our
behaviors and habits how we influence
the composition of this indoor
microbiome that we're living as
constantly so before i get into the
results i should tell you a little bit
about how we actually gather our data
and measure the composition of these
microbial communities and so most of you
who are familiar with microbiology know
that most microbes are not easily
distinguished just by looking at them
they are very similar morphologies and
cell types and even with a litany of
biochemical tests it can still be very
difficult to distinguish bacterial
species in particular from each other
and in addition to that we know that the
vast majority of microbial life is not
easily cultivated in the lab and so this
precludes us from being able to study
all of the microorganisms that live both
in the body and in the environment in in
culture this is an interesting figure
from a recent revision to the tree of
life kind of centered on the microbial
diversity of life and so this is this
was published by hug and colleagues
earlier this year and let me just get my
annotation tools here and so what you
see on this top portion of the graph
here this represents all of the
microbial diversity of nearly a hundred
bacterial phyla that have that have had
genomes sequenced and one thing to
notice here is that all of these red
dots that you see throughout the tree
those represent genomes from bacterial
or other organisms that have never been
cultivated in the lab so we see that
there's this extreme diversity of
microbial life but most of it we still
haven't even been able to study in
culture and so this is why it's really
important to have other means of
accessing the diversity of
microorganisms and then just to point
out where we are we are way down here in
a tiny branch in the eukaryotes and so
really microbial life is incredibly
diverse and best and because of that
this means that we need to rely on other
me
of accessing the diversity in these
communities and so the typical approach
that we take and this is this is typical
of most modern microbiome studies today
is we do a cultivation independent
workflow and so this means that we start
with our environmental sample whether
it's a soil sample or a dust sample and
then we extract DNA directly from the
sample we amplify marker genes and in
the case of bacteria we're most commonly
targeting the 16s ribosomal RNA gene and
then we sequence that so that we get DNA
sequences and perform bioinformatic
analyses that allow us to determine what
types of bacteria or fungi or other
organisms we have in a sample so today
everything that I'll show you is based
for the most part on 16s ribosomal RNA
sequencing and so this targets bacteria
so I mainly be focusing on bacteria
today but we do have other research with
fungi and we're starting to branch out
into other domains of life as well okay
so now to get into some results I'll
start with the design focused results so
how does architectural design influence
the microbiome of the built environment
and the first study that I'll share with
you is the first study that was done by
by members of the by OBE Center and so
this work was led by dr. steven campbell
who was at the time a postdoc at the bio
ve center and he's now an associate
professor at the University of Quebec
and Montreal and so the question that
Steve asked was how does the ventilation
source so the source of air circulating
through a building how does that
influence the composition of the air
microbiome specifically in hospital
rooms and the reason they decided to
start here was because if you think
about the relevance of the built
environment to human health one of the
first types of buildings that should
come to mind is a hospital you have a
lot of people who are recovering from
illness you know staying here and so
it's really important to assess how the
composition of the air microbiome and
also the indoor air quality might be
contributing to you know whether a
patient becomes more or less susceptible
and so in this study they had
researchers occupied patient rooms on a
patient bed for if
two hours at a time while they sampled
air and so i'm going to show you more of
the experimental details on that first
of all the the study was performed at
this hospital in Portland Oregon
Providence Milwaukee Hospital you can
see that it's a fairly standard looking
building modern building with hvac
circulation throughout the building
which is typical of most commercial
buildings and so here's a layout of a
typical patient room and so over here
you can see the patient bed you have the
window off to the side here and then a
bathroom over here and so these red
boxes here are showing the air intake on
this end and then the air exhaust on
this end and so typically air is
circulating through the room through
mechanical ventilation which as I said
is common for commercial buildings and
let me just zoom in a little bit on this
so there were two different treatments
that the researchers tested in this
study they wanted to compare
mechanically ventilated rooms with
window ventilated rooms and so what they
did was for mechanical ventilation they
circulated the air as you would normally
have it circulating throughout the room
coming in through the ceiling plenum and
out through the exhaust and during that
sampling they had two air collectors set
up right at the patient bed here and so
these are liquid air imp in jerz that
are drawing air through this device and
collecting the sample the particles in
the air collecting that inside on a
filter and so that was for mechanical
ventilation and then for window
ventilated rooms what they did was they
blocked off the mechanical supply of air
with this device that you see up here so
this is just channeling the what the air
that would normally be coming into the
room through the HVAC system back out
through the window and instead they're
just ventilating straight through the
window and letting out fresh outdoor air
into the hospital room you can see these
little yellow tell tales these are flags
that we use to measure air speed and
velocity and then these anemometer
probes this is another device a sensor
that's used to measure
flow and in addition to these two
treatments so mechanical ventilation and
window ventilated rooms they also
collected air directly outside of the
building to capture kind of the source
air microbiome that could be coming in
through the window and so they set up
the same types of air samplers on the
ground just outside of the air intake to
the building okay so the first result
that I'm going to show you illustrates
that the bacterial diversity differs
with respect to each of those different
air sources that I just told you about
so on the y-axis here we have something
called phylogenetic diversity and what
this represents is the the overall
diversity of different types of
distantly related bacteria within the
sample and so you can see here that in
the outdoor air samples the phylogenetic
diversity is much higher than what was
observed in doors in the mechanically
ventilated rooms and what this means is
that we're sampling a greater variety of
different types of bacteria outdoors
than we are indoors and what's really
interesting is that if you compare that
to the window ventilated rooms here in
the center it's intermediate between the
air the mechanically ventilated rooms
and the outdoor air so this suggests
that we're bringing in enough of the
outdoor air that we're getting a greater
variety of different types of
microorganisms that is elevated above
the mechanically ventilated rooms but
not quite as high as outdoors and so
another thing that they looked at in
this study was not only the phylogenetic
diversity but also what the composition
of that the air microbiome was in those
different samples and since this is the
hospital one of the things they were
interested in is whether the
mechanically ventilated rooms were
tending to accumulate more human
associated bacteria and specifically
bacteria that could be potential
pathogens and so what they did was they
compared the DNA sequences that they
obtained from all of the bacteria and
compared them to a database of known
human pathogens and if they were greater
than ninety seven percent similar to a
known pathogen they classified it as a
potential pathogen and so now what
you're seeing here we've got that
phylogenetic diversity plotted on the
x-axis and so that's what I showed you
in the previous plot and then on the
y-axis now we have the proportion
bacterial sequences in each of those
samples that was closely related to a
human pathogen and so now what you can
see is that in the mechanically
ventilated rooms even though the overall
phylogenetic diversity of those
communities is lower they have a greater
proportion of of organisms that are
closely related to human pathogens and
again you see the outdoor air on this
sense there's a lower proportion and
then in the middle again we have
intermediate proportions in the window
ventilated communities and so again this
is illustrating how just by changing the
type of air circulation in the building
this can alter the composition and the
diversity of the indoor air microbiome
and so as I said this was the first
study that was done at the by obe Center
just to understand how something like an
architectural features such as
ventilation could impact the indoor
microbiome and this was focused at a
room level and so after this study the
researchers were interested in expanding
this and doing a much larger Experiment
and so as a as a follow-up study they
asked the question what factors drive my
indoor microbiome composition at the
building scale and so what I'm going to
show you in the next several slides is a
compilation of a couple of different
studies and this was led again by dr.
Steve Campbell and also dr. James meadow
who was also a postdoc at the center and
is now working at phylogeny and so for
this study the building that you see in
the background here is the Lillis
business complex at the University of
Oregon this is a building that was
completed in 2003 and it's a really
interesting building to study for
architectural and microbial ecology
purposes because for one it uses a lot
of sustainable design features and
different ventilation strategies that
allow us to tease apart some of these
architectural variables that we think
may be impacting microbial ecology and
so here's a schematic diagram of that
building the lowest business complex and
so you can see that there's four main
floors throughout the building the
bottom two floors here are dedicated
primarily to classroom spaces and so you
have larger open spaces that are going
to have greater occupancy with students
and then on the top two
floors here these purple rooms are
faculty member offices and so you have
smaller rooms that are occupied probably
by one person at a time for the most
part so this is this is interesting to
be able to study different space types
in this environment and then finally in
blue here of course we have bathrooms on
every level through the center portion
of this let me see if I can get my
highlighter back again through the
center portion of the building here you
see this large open atrium and so this
is another great feature of this
building where you have this large open
space where air can exchange and flow
through from the bottom floor up to the
top floor okay so in this study the
researchers collected several different
types of samples one of them was to
sample individual rooms so those
classrooms and offices and bathrooms and
we think of this as kind of short-term
scale sampling and so we're sampling air
and surfaces over a short period of time
and what this does is it provides a
snapshot of what types of bacteria were
present at you know very in a very short
period of time on the other hand they
also collected vacuum dust samples from
surfaces all throughout the building and
so this we think of dust I mean its
particles settling out from the air over
time and so this represents more of a
time integrated sample of the microbiome
in the building over you know the course
since it was since the dust was less
disturbed and so you can see in these
photos here that they sampled not only
the floors but also ledges and tops of
mirrors and shelves and doorways to get
a really comprehensive sample of the
dust microbiome in this building they
sampled nearly 300 different spaces
throughout the building and it was that
covered approximately ninety three
percent of the building area okay so
with those two types of samples we're
interested in asking again what the
effect of different types of ventilation
are on the building and also what the
effects of space type and layout of the
building are so I'm going to show you
some results from that okay so this
first result is looking at the dust
microbiome see these are all of those
vacuum samples that they collected
throughout
building and this diagram that I'm
showing you here is an ordination
diagram and so what this shows you each
point here represents a single dust
sample that was collected from a
different space type and so you can see
the rooms over here we had classrooms
storage rooms and mechanical rooms
hallways offices and restrooms and so
the way to interpret this is that the
the closer and space two points are to
each other that means that their overall
microbial community composition was more
similar than two other points in this
plot and so if we break this down and
look at these five major types of spaces
we see that there's differences in both
the composition and the variants
observed in the composition in each of
these room types and so for instance you
see all the restroom samples down here
are clustered fairly closely together
suggesting that they're quite different
from any of these other space types it
turns out that many of the microbes that
were dominant in this environment were
human gut associated microorganisms not
too surprising and then in other areas
the storage and mechanical rooms you see
a lot of different types of communities
here and that could potentially be a
reflective of these spaces being
accessed lists frequently by fewer
people and so you don't have as much
mixing between the errors you might in a
restroom where you have a lot of traffic
going in and out and so what they found
was that looking at how these space
types fall apart on this diagram here
the higher human traffic areas tend to
cluster down here so hallways classrooms
and restrooms and then the lower traffic
areas storage rooms and offices cluster
up here but have a lot more spread and
so this was an interesting result that
illustrates how just by looking at
different types of rooms in a building
you can find different types of
microbial communities in addition to
that a really interesting feature of the
Lewis building is that the offices on
the top two floors have a mixed
ventilation system so all of the offices
on the north side of the building have
operable windows and can receive outdoor
air through natural ventilation and then
the south side show here in red
the Southside offices have your typical
mechanically ventilated air supply and
so in this diagram what we're showing is
the difference the primary bacterial
taxa that are contributing to
differences in the air between
mechanically ventilated and window
ventilated rooms and something that was
intriguing was that in the window
ventilated rooms a lot of the bacteria
that we're contributing to differences
from the mechanically ventilated rooms
were organisms that we commonly find
outdoors and in soil and so just like we
saw in the hospital study that's
reflective of exchange of that outdoor
air coming in and mixing with indoor air
introducing a greater variety of outdoor
associated microorganisms to the
environments and so I mentioned a few
slides back that the lowest building is
really interesting architectural II and
it has this large atrium in the center
of it and so this is just looking from
from the center of the building and you
can see the on each of these floors you
have hallways coming off of those and
each hallway has many rooms connected to
them and so this building also allowed
us to look at the effect of spatial
connections between rooms on the
composition of the microbiome and so
what I'm showing here this is a network
diagram showing the connections between
the different types of rooms in the
building and so you don't need to look
at this in too much detail but what you
have here each of these nodes or dots
represents a room in the building so all
these little blue ones are offices these
larger red ones are classrooms these
bright green circles are hallways or
other open corridors and the bathrooms
are here in yellow I believe and so what
you see between these connections that
this represents the area of connection
between any two rooms and so these
really broad connections indicate where
you have hallways connecting spaces
these really small connections means
that there's one door basically linking
that office to that hallway and then
these big gray circles represent outdoor
contact to the outdoor environment and
so you can see that this is a pretty
complex network of connections
and some spaces are more highly
connected than than others and so what
Steve Campbell and colleagues asked was
how does this spatial architecture of
layout of rooms relate to similarity in
microbial community composition and so
what I have here on the left side here
this x-axis is basically a simplified
version of the connectedness between any
two rooms and so we can think of it as
how many doors are there between in two
rooms and then on the y-axis here I'm
plotting a measure of biological
similarity so the higher this is that
means that those communities are more
similar to each other in composition and
so what you see here is an interesting
decay of similarity the further away two
spaces get and this may seem somewhat
intuitive because as two rooms are
further spaced apart they're going to be
experiencing less exchange of the same
microbes and so their communities are
going to become less similar to each
other and what's what I think is really
interesting about this is that this
echoes patterns that are observed in
other areas of ecology where people have
gone out and looked at soil communities
or plant communities or animals and you
see again this distance decay pattern as
you increase space between ecosystems
you have more dissimilarity between the
species that inhabit that and so this
suggests that you know there's potential
to model building ecosystems using
ecological approaches of distance and
similarity okay so all of the results
that I've presented up until this point
have shown how architectural factor
factors such as ventilation strategy and
space type and connections between rooms
all of those can impact the composition
of indoor microbiome and similarity
between micro biomes and different
spaces and so now what I want to
transition to is looking at how human
interactions with the built environment
can also contribute to differences in
the indoor microbial communities and so
this first study was part of this larger
Lilith's sampling effort and this was
led by dr. James meadow and the question
that he was asking is how to human
interactions with various surfaces
in this case in a classroom environment
how does that shape the composition of
the indoor microbiome and so you can see
here on this slide they sampled some
areas of desks and chairs you also see
floors and walls and we're interested in
understanding how the microbial
composition varies with respect to these
different surfaces and also how people
interact with those surfaces and so
here's a schematic diagram showing the
sampling of those classroom surfaces
this is just a top-down view of the
classroom so you can see at the front of
the room here this is where the
professor would be lecturing and then
you have all of these seats locate and
desks around the room facing the front
and so each of these little dots
represents a sampling location and the
colors are indicated here so they
sampled chairs desks walls over here by
the doors and also the floor at each
desk okay so here's a result from that
this is showing the differences among
those for space types and how it's
related to different types of bacteria
so over here we have a constrained
ordination showing that the chairs
floors walls and desks are different in
terms of microbial composition and then
over here this accompanying graph is
showing what types of bacteria most
explain those differences and so one
thing that was really interesting here
is that if you focus on the microbes
that were found on chairs and on desks
these tended to be organisms that are
commonly found in both the human gut and
urogenital tracks and also the skin
microbiome and this is not too
surprising because we carry those types
of organisms you know honor on our
bodies and so when we're interacting
with the surfaces of desks or sitting on
chairs we're presumably depositing some
of our microbes there on the other hand
the floors tended to have more organisms
that are typical of outdoor soil
communities and then on the walls these
were less distinctive of either soil or
human and and more types of bacteria
that we commonly see just an indoor air
and so this this is evidence to show
that the ways in which we interact with
different
Micro environments within the built
environment that we should we shape the
composition of what ends up there so
another way that we can think about our
interactions with the environment beyond
just our you know direct contact with
surfaces is actually the chemicals that
we apply indoors and so this is an area
of interest of dr. erica hartmann and
she was a postdoc at the x obe center
until very recently she just started an
assistant professorship at the
northwestern university and so she's
really interested in understanding how
the chemicals that we use indoors
affects the microbial composition and
also antibiotic resistance in the indoor
microbiome and so you may be aware that
many of the products that we use both
for personal care and even increasingly
just some consumer products like I'm
showing here keyboards and pencils and
building supplies many of these consumer
products are laced with antimicrobial
chemicals and here's just a table
showing one of the most ubiquitous of
them so triclosan which is probably the
most notorious evolved antimicrobials
that we use this is a summary of four
different studies that looked at the
concentrations of this chemical just an
indoor dust and so you can see the
nearly a hundred percent of samples had
detectable levels of triclosan and these
are slightly below active levels of of
the chemical but still we're finding a
lot of this in these different
environments and so this should be
concerning for a few reasons one is that
you know we're adding antimicrobials too
many of these products but it hasn't
scientifically been shown that these are
effective or any more effective at
removing bacteria than you know simply
using soap and water for instance and so
it's possible that we're potentially
enriching for ni microbial resistance in
the bacteria that live in an indoor
environment just by applying you know
blindly applying these chemicals to the
environment and so these studies you
know found triclosan
dust but up until this point no one had
asked well how does this relate to the
microbiome and so that was Erica's main
interest and so in this study we sampled
a different University of Oregon
building this is growing your hall this
is a much older building than the lowest
building that I showed you earlier so
this building was constructed in 1921
and it's a multi-use athletic and
classroom facility so this has
classrooms as you can see on the right
here offices of course restrooms and
then also gymnasiums locker rooms and a
swimming pool and so this represented a
really interesting building to do the
study of antimicrobial resistance on
because for one there are a lot of
different space types and yeah a lot of
opportunity to collect even more dust
and so you can see sorry you can see
vacuuming here we sampled light fixtures
area rugs bathrooms nooks and crannies
and we suspect that many of these areas
had probably not been cleaned for
possibly decades some of these areas
were very hard to reach and so we did a
comprehensive sampling of the dust
microbiome in this building and then
what we did with the samples instead of
just looking at the composition of the
microbial communities we saved half of
the sample to perform chemical analysis
on and so Erica's team led a chemical
analysis using liquid chromatography
tandem mass spec to look at the
concentrations of a variety of different
antimicrobial chemicals including
triclosan in the dust and then we
compared that to the composition of the
microbial communities in the dust in
addition to that we also did metagenomic
sequencing which this is a technique
that takes into account not just the
single marker gene but actually
evaluates all of the DNA in the sample
that we extract and so we targeted
antimicrobial resistance genes that were
present in those communities to try to
correlate whether the presence of
antimicrobials was correlated with an
elevated amount of antibiotic resistance
genes and so here I'm showing a couple
results we did find significant
associations between the concentrations
of both triclosan and methyl paraben in
association with several groups of
antibiotic resistance genes and so here
I'm showing just the top three of these
two of them were these 23 s ribosomal
RNA methyltransferases and so these
genes are involved in antibiotic
resistance to several different
compounds we also identified a class a
beta-lactamase shown here so these are
just the three most abundant but we
actually found more than this throughout
the data and then what you can see over
here these each of these plots is
showing the relative abundance of that
gene in the community plotted against
the mean chemical concentration of
triclosan in that in that community and
so you do see a statistically
significant correlation between higher
levels of triclosan and higher relative
abundance of these antibiotic resistance
genes in some samples but not all
samples and so this is is the first
instance where we've been able to
correlate the composition of the
microbiome and specifically looking at
antibiotic resistance genes and
connecting that to concentrations of
triclosan and dust and so erica is
currently working on a larger follow-up
study to this to look at other types of
buildings and environments to see if
this if this pattern exists you know
there as well but I don't want to alarm
you too much so we also as part of this
study compared the overall abundance of
antibiotic resistance genes to other
environments that have been studied and
so just to orient you with this diagram
this is these are violin plots which are
basically box Fox here you have the
median and the first and third quartiles
indicated in the boxes here and so these
lines on the outside simply represent
the distribution of data points along
that distribution and so this is from
our study these are the total basically
the total abundance of resistance genes
that we identified and then this is a
compilation of several other studies
looking at letak gyms and homes and then
finally over here this is looking at
antibiotic resistance genes in a cohort
of human microbiome samples and so we
can see that even though we have some
elevated resistance genes in our sample
and also in other built environments
it's also still high in the human
microbiome and so we don't fully
understand why this is the case yet but
this is an important factor to consider
when we're thinking about how we apply
both antimicrobials in the environment
and also antibiotics as humans you know
taking antibiotic medications these
things can potentially have impacts on
selecting for antibiotic resistance in
the micro biomes that live both in the
environment and also in our bodies and
so there's a lot of additional work to
be done in this area and this is kind of
an emerging area of research but we
think it's really important to consider
and so many of you might have heard
about this news last week and we think
this is good news the FDA recently
recommended that 19 of these
antimicrobial chemicals that are
commonly used in hand soaps and personal
care products these are no longer going
to be allowed in the US and so this does
include triclosan you can visit this
link here for more information but
basically they concluded that there
wasn't enough scientific evidence to
support the claim that add addition of
these chemicals was any more effective
than just using soap and water so we
were really happy to see this and with
you know timely publication of our these
results were actually just published
today from from the study I just showed
you so I encourage you to go look this
up in environmental science and
technology yeah so that's kind of a
summary of the research that we've done
at the bio bees Center over the last six
years oh sorry I have one more study
almost forgot about one of my favorites
here so now at this point I've shown you
how architectural features including
ventilation and space type can influence
the microbiome I've shown you how
interactions with surfaces and
application of antimicrobial chemicals
could also potentially have an impact
and so one of the observations that was
continually made through all of these
studies is that many of the bacteria
that we usually observe in the micro in
the indoor microbiome are bacteria that
are commonly associated with humans and
so we presume that the microbes are
getting there through humans shedding
them into the indoor environment but no
one had actually measured this before
and so this last study i'm going to show
you focuses on the human microbial cloud
and what I mean by that is the microbial
cloud you can think of as all of the
particles that are being shed by a
person into their surroundings and those
particles have microbes attached to them
and so this work was also led by dr.
James meadow and he was asking the
question how do individuals micro biomes
actually colonize the built environment
and so in order to do this you need a
fairly well controlled system or
container where you can sample a human
microbial cloud and what you see here in
this background picture this is the
climate chamber at the energy studies in
buildings laboratory in Portland Oregon
and so you can see two people sitting in
chairs here and I'll show you just in a
slide the experimental setup in a little
bit more detail but what you see here
there's air samplers set up around each
person so at both head height and lower
closer to the four floor and so we
sampled the air microbiome around people
inside of this closed room so here's a
schematic diagram of what this climate
chamber looks like it's about the size
of a you know a small office here's a
person for scale and so inside this
chamber all of the walls have radiant
heating panels and so you can adjust
both the temperature and humidity of the
room there's also this air supply duct
where you can control whether what type
of ventilation you have whether its
natural ventilation or indoor mechanical
ventilation and we also have a ceiling
fan up here so we can really control all
of the building variables that we think
matter for contributing to microbial
ecology and I should mention that this
climate chamber was originally developed
for architectural research on thermal
comfort research and so we've kind of
co-opted it for our own purposes and
using to use it as a giant petri dish of
sorts and so on the right side here you
can this is illustrating the
experimental setup of having a person
sitting in the chamber and so what they
did was they put up a plastic sheet just
across the width of the room here
effectively creating two smaller rooms
and so half of the room remained
unoccupied you see an empty chair here
the top down and we set up air samplers
just around the outside of that chair to
collect air on the other side of the of
the wall here we had a person sitting in
a chair for two or four hours and again
collecting air samples and so we use the
same cultivation independent techniques
of extracting DNA from these air filters
and amplifying bacterial genes and then
comparing the community composition in
those different space types and what we
found was that an occupied space does in
fact have a distinct microbiome from
that adjacent unoccupied space and so
again I'm showing some ordination
diagrams like I showed you earlier where
each of these points represents a single
air sample that was taken from around
the perimeter of one of those chairs so
the triangles represent the unoccupied
room and the circles represent the
occupied room from three different
subjects there were ten subjects total
in this study and so you can see by
looking at each of these that the
occupied spaces are quite distinct from
the unoccupied spaces and on the right
side of the diagram here this is just
clustering all of those data points
together in a dendrogram and so you can
see that most of the human associated
rooms tend to cluster down here whereas
the unoccupied spaces cluster up here
and have a lot more variability and so
this was the first evidence to really
demonstrate that an empty room looks
different from a room with a person
sitting in it even just for a couple of
hours and we consuming further than that
and look at some of the distinguishing
bacterial taxa that were identified in
though in those air samples and so here
we're showing again another dendogram
clustering several samples from five
different individuals and then along the
bottom here we have some of the most
distinguishing bacteria taxa that we
could find to that characterize each of
those people and so you can see that
this person a here in Orange has a
pretty distinct signature of
lactobacillus Chris bodice whereas most
of the other people here do not
similarly subjects d here and I should
mention that both subjects a and D were
female and so both of these organisms
lactobacillus and gardnerella are
organisms that you commonly find in the
female urogenital tract and so we're
also detecting those in the air sampled
around them
and so you can see that this individual
had strong signature of this organism
that was not as common in the others and
so on and so forth you can see that for
each of these people you have kind of
these unique fingerprints or microbial
signatures and again this is just from
sampled from the air around the people
this isn't from their skin microbiome or
you know sampling the person directly
themselves and so this shows us that
just by sampling error we can identify
if a person is in a room if you're
interested in hearing a little bit more
about this science friday did a piece on
this back in january and here i am
sitting as a guinea pig in the climate
chamber so i encourage you to go check
that out if you're interested but we
don't have time to watch that right now
and so that was a fun project that we
did with science writing okay so just to
wrap up I want to come back to this
original question that I started with
how does the design use and occupancy of
buildings influence the indoor
microbiome is where I started and so all
of the research that I've shown you has
has looked at the ways in which we
design and use buildings influences the
built environment microbiome and so the
work that we're doing now is trying to
incorporate that top of that triangle
and bringing human health and the human
microbiome back into the picture and so
the what I'm really interested in in
doing with my research is kind of
completing this loop so we've shown in a
lot of ways that humans directly impact
the composition of the indoor microbiome
both by shedding their microbes indoors
and also by the ways that we design
buildings and interact with surfaces in
those buildings all of that can alter
the composition of the indoor microbiome
and so what I'm really intrigued by is
how does what's already in that indoor
environment contribute back to the human
microbiome and ultimately impact human
health and so this is kind of a theme of
our ongoing research projects now I'm
just going to highlight very briefly a
couple of these just to wrap up and so
these are projects that were actively
working on hopefully stay tuned in the
next few months we'll have some results
from each of these and so one of the the
studies that I'm currently doing this is
a follow-up to that microbial cloud
study that I just showed you a few
slides back and in this case instead of
just having one person in a room we have
multiple people sit in a room
cc3 chairs here set up and the questions
that we're asking here are first of all
how far into space does a person's
microbial cloud extend so if someone is
sitting over here can you still pick up
their microbes all the way across the
room or are they staying fairly well
localized and secondly when we do have
multiple people in a room are we still
able to pick out microbes that
distinguish each of these individuals
from each other in the air that were
sampling throughout the room and so I
think that this research could have
really interesting applications for just
understanding the dynamics of
transmission of microbes from person to
person through air and also there's
potential for forensic applications
where you know we can distinguish you
know who was in this room just based on
the air that we sampled in the room at a
given point in time that could be
potentially useful for forensic
applications as well and so this work is
actively ongoing stay tuned for results
another area that we're focusing on
right now is looking at a different
built environment the home microbiome
and so we're specifically asking how
things that interventions that humans
make to their homes by making
weatherization improvements to improve
energy consumption or you know keep your
homes warmer during the winter how does
that impact the composition of the
indoor microbiome and so this is a study
that we're collaborating with members of
the Oregon Research Institute and also a
company called inhabit up in Portland
that puts contractors in touch with
homeowners to do these weatherization
improvements and so we're conducting a
study in two different climatic zones in
Oregon cortland and Bend which is a high
desert region and we're sampling air
inside homes using both petri dishes so
these are just collecting settled dust
and also we're taking a bunch of indoor
air quality measurements for different
chemicals that are circulating through
the air and we're asking how the act of
effectively sealing up the building
envelope of your house by performing
weatherization improvements how is that
shaping the indoor microbiome
composition and so and finally there's a
third study that I'm working on it I'm
really excited about and this is again
looking at how
microbes are potentially being
transmitted to humans via the built
environment and so this is work that I'm
doing with a graduate student in the lab
Ashley Bateman and we're comparing three
different approaches of how microbes
could be getting transferred to humans
and you'll see here that we're working
with pet dogs and houseplants as our
sources of microbes and the reason that
we're focusing on these is because other
research studies have demonstrated that
these organisms contribute a lot of
microbes to the indoor environment and
that could be important for for the
composition of our own human microbiome
and also health and allergies and that
sort of thing and so we're comparing
three different modes of transfer where
one of them is direct contact so can a
person pick up microbes just by touching
the dog or the houseplant the second one
here we're collecting dust from dogs and
plants onto surfaces and then having
people interact with that and so this is
asking the question can we actually
colonize just by touching surfaces in
the built environment and then finally
we're looking at transfer of bio
aerosols and so if you're just in the
same room as a dog or a plant or a room
that was previously occupied by a dog or
a plant does that alone Colin enable
colonization of the human skin
microbiome and so this is work that
we're actively doing and I think it's
really exciting because this is going to
help to close that loop to try to
understand how the built environment
microbiome is potentially shaping the
human microbiome and here's just an
illustration of how we collect some of
these samples and so we have and this
instance we got some house plants in
here where we're collecting dust samples
and then we transfer either through
direct contact or through contact with
surfaces once the skin microbiome and
then we swab over time so this is just a
fun little picture showing how we do
some of that work okay so coming back to
this theme that I started with in the
beginning again we're really trying to
bridge connections between each of these
areas to try to understand how microbial
ecology of the built environment
ultimately impacts human health and so I
just want to close with some open
questions that we're currently thinking
about in our research and one of them
this relates to some
those distance decay patterns that I
showed you earlier where we saw that the
architectural layout of buildings
relates to similarity in microbial
communities and so this leads us to
wonder are there general laws and
building ecology that we can predict and
model based on architectural variables
because we know that in much of ecology
we're interested in seeking general
patterns and principles across space and
time so can we apply similar approaches
to the building ecosystem another big
open question of course is specifically
how the built environment and human
health are related and so something that
I think is really exciting is that you
know for most of the history of
microbiology and built environment
research it's mainly been focused on
pathogens and trying to keep microbes
out of buildings but now that we're
starting to understand that you know we
can't first of all we can't get rid of
those microbes but also that we need a
lot of those microbes to be healthy how
can we actually design the built
environment to promote human health and
so this is a really big motivating
question for us and then finally we're
interested in understanding the
mechanisms of microbial exchange between
buildings air and people and so this
relates to the microbial cloud work that
I just showed you where we're trying to
understand exactly how microbes are
making their way both to and from humans
and the built environment and so with
that we've got a few minutes left I'm
just want to wrap up and acknowledge a
lot of people who have contributed to
this work over the years in the top here
we have the principal investigators so
jessica greene kevin banda y melon
birdie charlie brown all at the
university of oregon we also collaborate
heavily with Curtis Hutton power and
Ralph Halden and then a whole bunch of
people that have contributed to these
projects over the years we get funding
from the Alfred P sloan Foundation and
also the Environmental Protection Agency
for the weatherization study that I
mentioned a few slides back so we want
to thank both of them and if you're
interested in learning more about the
research that we're doing you can follow
us at our website the biology in the
built environment center you can also
email me directly or either of the
co-directors of the bio de center or
follow any of us on twitter we'd be
really excited to hear from you any
questions you have or ideas you know we
love doing this research and
getting feedback from from people so
thank you for for listening i think we
have just a couple minutes left for
questions but i really appreciate you
attending my presentation and I'll turn
it back over to Robert
I thank you very much doctor for your
presentation and I also like to think
rabble a brutes as well for sponsoring
this particular event um but dr. do you
have to hear one final question that we
have here that we have time for right
now see oh I do apologize with the time
it's time that we do have doctors there
aren't any final statements that you
would have at this point in time to wrap
things up hi um no I don't think I have
any final statements I just want to
thank everyone again for attending and I
would encourage you to keep an eye on
built environment research this is a
really active and nascent field of study
where we're trying to draw these
connections between the organisms that
live indoors with us and the human
microbiome and so I'm really excited for
the opportunity to be able to work on
this and I think that there's a lot of
potential for research particularly with
respect to the antimicrobial resistance
and also just the transfer of microbes
from the built environment the human
microbiome and yeah so I just want to
say thank you again to all of our
attendees and the organizers of the
meeting and also my advisor dr. Greene
for giving me the opportunity to share
this research with all of you today
thank you
thank you doctor and today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 7th you'll receive an
email from us a learning when it is
available on demand and posted on lab
routes comm you're welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues that
weren't able to join us today and we
thank you very much for logging on in
participating in today's live webinar
see you next time